the founders of the clothing retailer
lularoe are hitting back at critics of
the company lularoe has thousands of
independent sellers nationwide this year
the company was hit with a number of
complaints about quality and refund
policies a 1 billion dollar lawsuit
filed in October alleges it's a pyramid
scheme and a warner spoke with the
company's co-founders to learn their
response to these accusations and a good
morning good morning bianna well lularoe
tells us it's confident it will prevail
against what the company calls meritless
litigation earlier this year Lulu Rose
founders sat down to defend themselves
against various allegations and spoke
out about their clothing business which
they claim has been a runaway success
since they started it about five years
ago we have a multi-billion dollar
business it was not built by tricking
people into giving us their money to
here lularoe co-founders Marc and Deanne
stidham tell it their story is one of a
successful family-run business built on
hard work and creativity we have a
clothing line that people love they love
its comfort they love its versatility
they love the fashion that clothing line
began with Deann Stephens handmade
creations and grew to become a business
they say has had over two billion
dollars in sales so far this year made
through a network of some 80,000
independent sellers or consultants who
sell online or through home parties much
as stidham herself first did and I often
say lularoe works for you you don't work
for lularoe that means you get to decide
on your time and you get to decide what
works best for you it is in saying you
will be able to have a full time income
and it's life changing online some
consultants say they've made good money
or we've done just a little bit over two
hundred thousand and say
for this last year you get the product
you put it before people and you sell it
and you have money and that's the
simplicity of this business and it's
that's as easy as it can be
Lulu Rose approach what's called
multi-level marketing retailers buy in
with a minimum purchase in Lulu Rose
case about $5,000 then sell to customers
at a markup they can also make money by
recruiting other sellers to join their
team and make bonuses off those
retailers sales the company points to
success stories like the consultant they
introduced us to in California miss TL
Sasser hi hi how you guys doing
Elsa sir started 3 years ago when there
were just 700 sellers nationwide and now
has more than 11,000 members in her
Facebook group I love lularoe
I wear it every single day she says her
profits are upwards of 3 grand a month
for me I really focus on what's
important for our family and for my
business and you've been able to pay
your mortgage with this yes it all
sounded good to chicago-area
stay-at-home mom Susan counsel who said
a recruiter told her it's very minimal
part-time work for full time income
you'd have lots of time you know extra
money for you know to do whatever you
want with your family so counsel said
she invested around $11,000
but despite working more than full-time
hours couldn't make it work and in
November said she was still over $4,000
in debt
I felt like I failed my family I put my
family into debt to do something that
ended up not being what they preached
and she's not the only one complaining a
recently filed lawsuit seeking a billion
dollars claims tens of thousands of
other consultants never even made a
profit because lularoe
they allege is a pyramid scheme that
only profited a few and only made
payments to consultants based on how
much product those consultants and their
recruits purchased on a regular basis
what that is is an educated opinion they
haven't looked at who we are because we
sell product through to a consumer and
it's highly desirable product
that is not a pyramid scheme should they
think it's easy no I think it's easy
that's me okay for me in my background
and my life experience I do not say it's
easy for whatever is the thing some
consultants say they were told this is
easy and that's what I think they heard
and it's not the truth but they did say
that while more than half of lularoe
sellers some 40,000 make a thousand
dollars or more per month a small group
at the top pulls in $500,000 or more per
year in bonuses made off the sellers
below them and Douglas Brooks an
attorney who has sued other multi-level
marketing companies says for the vast
majority of people that that get into a
company like this they're going to be
lucky if they break even these women are
out there saying look it's a con it's a
scam it's pyramid scheme don't do it
what do you think is happening to those
retailers I will tell you that we have
been incredibly disruptive in the
marketplace and I don't think that those
are all entirely organic complaints you
think somebody's putting him up to it
my personal belief is that yes well
student wouldn't say precisely who he
believed might have been trying to
generate complaints against the company
but said that he thinks other companies
are targeting Lulla roads retailers to
try to copy the company's success
meanwhile one marketing expert told us
he doesn't think it's an actual pyramid
scheme but that doesn't mean it's a good
business opportunity for everyone the
company says its retailers are seeing
tremendous success but some consultants
continue to complain they're having a
tough time getting refunds and lularoe
says it's making improvements to those
processes but on Facebook
there are similar patterns to what we
saw a couple months ago which are some
of the consultants who bought in saying
I bought in I can't get out I can't get
my stuff sold so definitely more than
one side to this picture yeah a lot of
it though it just seemed based on work
ethic - you said some of these
consultants are just working non-stop
trying to sell these products well some
of the ones who work around stop do
really well and then there are people
who say I was working non-stop
and I still couldn't make it work so I
think they're many of these people are
working hard but what is
it take to become successful in any
business and one of the things that the
experts we talked to said is you really
have to look at it as a business there's
no guarantee Yeah right you have to tell
you all the time no such thing as easy
money yes right Anna thank you